why didn't Bernie win the big turning
point was South Carolina
South Carolina was when Joe Biden won
and won handily
understood to be because of the larger
African-American population in South
Carolina
and right around that exact same time I
actually don't remember now whether it
was the day after or the day before some
of the smaller Democratic candidates
smaller in terms of support got out and
said I'm endorsing Joe Biden and to some
degree of course it was all organized
and timed to help Joe Biden there's no
doubt about that this is what the DNC
does it's hard for me to be mad at the
DNC because this is sort of like if if
we believed they were there to be
unbiased Arbiters and to stay as much on
the side as possible it would make sense
to be furious that they've gone against
their stated you know kind of mandate
but we know that the DNC
negotiates